our first stop on our journey across
America is the Chilton branch in
southern Arizona this is cowboy country
and if you think Cowboys are a thing of
the past just take a look at Jim Chilton
and his crew Jim's Cowboys are saddling
up to ride out to the thousand cattle of
the Chilton Raj they see you down there
Jim takes us out to explore his land
50,000 mountainous acres stretching down
to Mexican border for years this was a
prime route for illegal immigration now
drug cartels have taken over Jim
describes one time he ran into them some
drug Packers were on the ridge and they
had seen me with their binoculars and
washed me with my gun and when I
approached him they jumped and ran and
they left for big 60 70 pound packs of
marijuana Jim placed some hidden cameras
to show drug packers walking on his
trails he tells us these images are from
earlier this year but why is it so easy
for people to get through we head down
to the border to find out it's a slow
two hour drive before we get out to hike
the last quarter mile lugging our gear
along with us finally we make it and
discover that here the us-mexican border
is just a flimsy wire fence about a
meter high it's a very poor excuse for
an international boundary I mean it's
laughable it's hilarious to think that
the United States boundary on my ranch
is nothing but a four strand barbed-wire
fence Jim once the fence replaced with a
wall plus access roads and basis for the
Border Patrol right now they're
stationed three hours north of here
making Jim's entire ranch a kind of
no-man's land
a couple of hundred miles away in the
capital of Phoenix volunteers are
getting ready for a day out on the
doorstep they're part of a push to get
Hispanic citizens registered to vote in
time for election day it's a nonpartisan
project but for many the motivation is
clear stopping Donald Trump for Claudia
Faldo it's important work she's one of
America's 11 million undocumented
immigrants someone who doesn't have a
vote of her own so this is her way of
participating the election today she
signs up a young man and an older woman
to vote he's very cute actually to to
help him to get registered so she can
vote for me I told her please don't
forget to vote because these these
elections you are my boys overall the
goal is to register more than a hundred
thousand new voters number that could be
enough to defeat Trump here in Arizona
later we head downtown where the Hillary
Clinton campaign is holding a small
event aimed at Hispanics for Claudia
beating Trump would be fitting revenge
for a man she says is demonizing people
like her there is a lot of hate here
like it's horrible it's just you know
like I don't want this country for my
kids we cannot let him that win he's
dangerous but Jim disagrees he says the
situation on his ranch cannot go on
we're foreign occupied why should I live
in a foreign occupied area with the
cartel Scouts on our mountains I mean
let's get serious why not have the
border patrol at the international
boundary why not have a wall and roads
and why not allow people to come in this
country legally the need for a wool
couldn't be more clear for Jim and his
wife sue but away from these Borderlands
it's more a symbol than anything real
and another dividing line among the many
cutting through America
you